[Music]
how it did the stunts in this film
differ from doing Deadpool to oh why
don't ya they're all them you don't
America lately different yeah doing
things in regular closes one yeah I
can't hide my wincing behind a mask in
this movie so yeah a lot of differences
Blake is going to be taking on an action
film are you helping her with the
training have you given her some
fighting tips why would I need to help
my wife with training or fighting tips
my wife can train and kick ass all on
her lonesome she don't need me for any
of that you're known for playing badass
characters with this one and Deadpool I
feel like do you just you you want to do
that like badass characters just to look
cool for the kids right I'm like so you
can be like kids look daddy was like a
badass I guess I don't think that I'm a
badass I don't think I play badasses
Deadpool's at like half the time it's
just a [ __ ] and that's what's so fun
about them and this guy is just a you
know an emotionally enough child so I
mean it's a you know and then you add
like handguns into it and it's just
dangerous okay part three one my bad
your bad
[Music]
you